last week a girl dm me like oh i've been
had a crush on you i like you so i d on
the back like you know let's let's link
up so i never didn't link up with her
but her her ex-boyfriend in my inbox
sending me a screenshot a hood talking
to her friend talking about girl gets me
in my inbox
like wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait crazy okay so you had a girl
hit you up she hit me up like first hey
i've been a fan you hit her back hey
let's kick it what's up her
ex-boyfriend then hit you up and was
like this screenshot of her she tried to
she
she didn't delete her messages to her
friend
so she dealing with a friend like girl
guess who been girl hd being in my inbox
all day i'm like we only sent four
messages so her ex boyfriend is
obviously salty
he wouldn't trip he was just let me i
know him oh you know him yeah he might
he my homeboy homeboy
so you're [ __ ] with your homeboy
homeboy i ain't never [ __ ] with her i
just was about to heal her ah but
she is that against dude code no he like
i don't know but we we we
do my homeboy homeboy so i mean oh
you're so he's your homie's homie my
homeboy is his homeboy okay so i ain't
we you guys let me ask you this
hypothetically speaking before you would
have [ __ ] his ex would you have hit
him up and be like hey i was going to
tell him okay i thought he'd do
after you hit yeah i ain't going to tell
you before because then you can act
surprised you could be like yo i didn't
even know man i just want you to know i
[ __ ] shorty man i didn't even know
until like no i had to finish on some
slick [ __ ] so i i i fell back from
did he send me a screenshot of her
texting her hunger and she was like uh
yeah he's been in my inbox all day he
ugly but i get some money from him what
so i was i so she called me acting like
she she all know i know what she knows
so she called me on some she like oh i
think my instagram got head cuz he got
my messages out there you know your
instagram you know exactly you dirty you
know what's going on
so i so about my business right there i
speak i'm on the speakerphone she's like
oh i mean i like you for real i just was
talking [ __ ] to my own girl like who the
[ __ ] talk she saying some [ __ ] like they
like you
you really clown chasing on some [ __ ]
super she's in it this is a conversation
a better rules girl who was standing
houston but guess how she ended the
conversation
um can i still talk to you i still want
to talk to you and you said no i was
like she said come on now i'm just going
to hit you just because you know
did you end up delivered
i ain't been back ain't she back in
bedrooms what's the difference between
like like baton rouge women and houston
women
houston women got more brains better
women think the same they all
crabs in the bucket